the theatrical cut of Justice League
disappointed critics and many fans but
now director Zack Snyder has gotten the
green light to make his original version
of the movie a reality we already know a
few things about what it'll look like
here's what bands can expect the biggest
issue that Warner Brothers reportedly
had was ax Niners version of Justice
League was that it was too long in 2017
the Wall Street Journal claimed that the
studio CEO had stepped in and demanded
that the film be trimmed down to two
hours a full hour shorter than Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice Snider managed
to turn in a version that ran for two
hours and 20 minutes before he departed
the project but that isn't the cut we're
going to see on HBO Mac's in 2021
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Snyder's quotes optimal version of
Justice League was actually four hours
long he was well aware that Warner
Brothers was unlikely to release a four
hour film in theaters but now that the
project is destined for streaming Snider
may actually get his wish stop right
there
I'm in in fact we may even get more than
four hours the director told thr that
the studio was considering releasing
Zack Snyder's Justice League as a series
after hosting some Warner Brothers execs
at his home to discuss the idea finally
releasing his version of Justice League
Snyder floated the idea of fleshing out
what they already had and creating six
chapters that would end with
cliffhangers the studio has reportedly
allocated twenty to thirty million
dollars to add the finishing touches to
the existing material so a six-part
Justice League series is a very real
possibility the extensive reshoots
conducted by replacement director Joss
Whedon drastically changed large
sections of Snyder's film and one of the
biggest victims was Ray Fisher's Victor
stone aka cyborg Snyder once told USA
Today Ray's story is in a lot of the
ways the part of the movie but the
character was on the periphery for much
of the theatrical cut his original story
was filmed but completely cut from the
final movie as were a number of big
moments involving his family speaking to
GameSpot Fisher revealed that he shot
some quote really special scenes with
Karen Bryson who played cyborgs mom that
wound up on the cutting room floor we
did get to meet cyborgs father Silas
stone the genius behind his son's
restoration but what we didn't see was
his dad's death in a post shared to his
Varro Schneider revealed the still from
his version of the movie that shows a
helpless cyborg reaching out as his
father is consumed by an explosion
according to vulture editor Kyle
Kanon snyder intended Silas stone to be
the voice in the movies closing
monologue he tweeted cyborg finds a
video from him at the end Whedon gave
those lines to Amy Adams piercing
Clemens was clearly excited to be
debuting his Barry Allen's longtime love
interest iris West the dope star was
meant to cameo in the team up movie but
she wasn't invited back for reshoots
when Whedon took the reins and in the
end her small scene was removed
altogether
Justice League chances are this scene
will be reinstated for Snyder's cut and
we even know what it's going to look
like because the rough version of it
leaked online in 2017 sources told
Batman news that Warner Brothers was at
one stage mulling over the idea of
completing the visual effects on the
scene so that it could be included as
part of the blu-ray release though the
studio was apparently considering
removing West from the equation and just
having the flash save a random person
instead this could well be how the scene
plays out in Snyder's upcoming cuts
though Snyder has always been a vocal
supporter of Clements and Miller's
partnership in November 2009 teen he
shared a still of the quotes cute couple
and character Jason Momoa as Arthur
curry spends most of his time above the
waves in the theatrical cut of Justice
League but don't expect that to be the
case in Snyder's finished version
according to Momoa he filmed scenes at
an underwater location that never made
it into Whedon's reshuffled film Momoa
told GameSpot's there's a place where
Aquaman goes down too and it got cut out
of the movie he knows spots where he can
go and he sees these statutes the
remnants of Atlantis the actor also
revealed that Willem Dafoe's volcko was
originally supposed to debut during the
section of the film but said there just
wasn't enough time
of course volcko went on to feature
heavily in 2018 Aquaman but now fans
will likely get a chance to see his
original introduction as Snyder intended
it
the king has risen there's also evidence
that amber herds Mira had a much larger
role in Snyder's version of the film
a pre bits that shows Aquaman's fellow
Atlantean in an extended battle with
Steppenwolf has been making the rounds
online for some time now pretty much
everyone on the original Justice League
cast has given their support to the
Snyder cut campaign at one stage Jesse
Eisenberg said he wasn't necessarily
part of quote the movement when he spoke
to the Toronto Sun in April 2020 but
added that if his version was ever
released quotes it would be great with
Warner Brothers confirming Snyder's
Justice League is finally coming we
should get to see more of Eisenberg in
action as iconic villain Lex Luthor
Eisenberg's return as Luthor was
announced pretty early on the character
was meant to play a larger role in the
film as a piece of leaked concept art
seemingly proves the mock-up scene shows
Luthor in a prison cell with what
appears to be a notebook nearby the fact
that Batman discusses the importance of
Luthor's journals and that the a triple
cut of the film could be a hint that the
Lex Corp CEO was vital to the plot at
one stage those squares Luthor's notes I
think they must be containers of some
kind of wall I don't know we're starting
a war over Eisenberg has confirmed that
he shot more than the end credits scene
even that will likely be different
Luthor's lying about the villains
needing a league of their own was
apparently Wheaton's idea and
Deathstroke actor Joe Manganiello has
confirmed that Snyder's version played
out differently even those with a mere
passing interest in the Snyder cuts have
long been aware that Darkseid was
supposed to debut in Justice League but
it might still be surprising to know
just how heavily the evil galactic God
was going to feature in the film
especially considering he's only
mentioned once in the theatrical cut for
the unity
with dark side Snyder has teased what he
had in store for dark side on numerous
occasions meaning we've been able to
piece together his intended Justice
League arc the director planned to use a
cosmic tyrant during the film's history
lesson segment in which Amazon's
Atlanteans and humans fight off an
invading force from apocalypse Snyder
reportedly planned to kick off the big
flashback with Wonder Woman discovering
a mural depicting this first invasion
led by Darkseid the director has also
given a glimpse of what this younger
version of Darkseid looks like but what
we're still waiting to see is his battle
with Ares actor Nick McKinley's has
confirmed that he shot an entire fight
sequence as the Greek god of war going
toe-to-toe Darkseid the climactic battle
ends when Wonder Woman shatters
Steppenwolf's axe with her sword and the
villains parademon army smells his spear
the creatures turn on him and they're
all sucked back to apocalypse through an
extra dimensional portal the idea of the
para demons being able to smell fear was
reportedly introduced by Whedon during
reshoots and that's not the only thing
he changed about the final showdown the
battle against Steppenwolf was supposed
to have a far more definitive and brutal
ending in a series of images that Snyder
shared to Barrow the director revealed
that the villain was going to meet his
end at Diana princes hand but it isn't
his axe that she slices through it's his
neck Snyder captioned his post not sure
how they killed Steppenwolf in the
theatrical version of Jael this was
never finished all the way but I use
Gods to kill gods we can also expect the
Amazon to have a major assist when the
scene plays out in 2019 Jason Momoa
shared a still image from the original
climax revealing that Aquaman and pales
Steppenwolf on his Trident before his
death according to storybook artists J
Olivia a quotes unhinged version of
Superman was also going to go to town on
Steppenwolf before Wonder Woman
delivered the killing blow one of the
most polarizing moments from Batman vs
Superman was the nightmare scene in
which Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne has a
vision of a ravaged post-apocalyptic
earth he watches over a burning city
with a huge Omega symbol and printed in
the ground below in DC fans know that
the Omega pretty much confirms that this
future is Darkseid's doing but nothing
ever came of the sequence
Snyder has since confirmed that he
intended to expand upon it in Justice
League but it never
happen a second nightmare sequence was
deemed surplus to requirements by Whedon
but expect to revisit this hellscape was
Schneider during the director's cut
event in 2019 he explained the truth is
that the nightmare sequence in this
movie is always something I intended to
explain there was a scene in the trailer
apparently it didn't make it into the
movie where Bruce says flash came to him
and warned him that Lois was the key and
something darker was coming that
something darker was of course darkside
who kills Lois Lane in order to turn
Superman bad Snyder confirmed fans have
been waiting to see Henry Cavill down
the black Superman suits on the big
screen ever since his version of the
Kryptonian kicked the bucket in Batman
vs Superman the black suit is deeply
connected to the death and rebirth of
Superman in the comics one of the iconic
characters most famous story arcs cavil
began teasing the black Superman suit
the year before justice league hit
theaters but the outfit didn't appear in
the final movie he can be seen walking
past the suit during a deleted scene
that made it to the blu-ray release but
in Snyder's original version he was not
only going to be wearing the black suits
he was going to be in it for the
entirety of the movie it appears as
though Superman's resurrection went down
very very differently in the Snyder cuts
in Whedon's version of the film the Man
of Steel gets angry with the Justice
League for a few moments before Lois
Lane quickly talks him down but Snyder
wouldn't have him be so easily placated
all the evidence points to a much bigger
battle between black suits Superman and
the Justice League who are not able to
reason with the Kryptonian quite as
successfully upon his resurrection one
of the early Justice League trailers
included a shot of cyborg protecting
some cops from a burning tank that the
rampaging Superman has apparently sent
flying their way Henry Lennox made his
debut as general Swanwick and Man of
Steel and was supposed to reprise the
role in Justice League but his character
didn't make the final cut
what just happened fans guessed back
when Man of Steel came out that Swanwick
was actually the shape-shifting alien
detective John Jones in disguise and
when Justice League went with the
tagline unite the seven early in
production it seemed clear that there
was one member of the team that had not
yet been revealed Snyder has since
confirmed that fans were absolutely
right
Swanwick was the Martian hero and he was
going to have more than one disguise in
October 2000 nineteen Snyder shared a
storyboard to Barrow that depicts Martha
Kent visiting Lois Lane after their
conversation Superman's mom briefly
turns into Martian Manhunter before
changing back to Swanwick the director
confirmed that he was able to shoot the
vast majority of the scene he just
needed to get a few more shots with
Lenox the actors seemed pretty excited
about the news that Snyder's version of
the film will finally be seen he tweeted
out a picture of his character along
with the caption read Justice League in
the Snyder cuts things don't just happen
things happen just Darkseid and Martian
Manhunter are perhaps the two biggest
characters that were cut from Justice
League when Whedon assumed control but
they were far from the only ones
responding to a fan on Barrow Snyder
revealed that the dialogue used in an
early trailer nature issues
tony was actually Steppenwolf speaking
to desaad darkside sadistic right-hand
man the sod was removed with Darkseid
leaving the movie two villains down when
it comes to cut characters however the
heroes took a bigger hit in Snyder's
vision for the movie the history lesson
sequence was going to feature a younger
version of Robin Wright's ante Opie
cider evidently like the character who
was killed during the attack on famous
Kyra and Wonder Woman and wanted to give
fans a brief glimpse of her past he also
confirmed that he intended to use a
different Green Lantern during the
invasion flashback we were supposed to
meet Ryan Choi aka the Adam Snyder
confirmed that the scientist who works
alongside Silas stone at STAR Labs was
going to be revealed as Choi back in
2018 and the director shared an image of
the character in action not long before
the HBO deal was announced writing this
will be fun check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]